so you've all been selected to be
doctors for the foundation heads of your
fields and all that well I'm here to
tell you that none of that matters here
you're just one of the rest
we have over 974 doctors among the
primary sites alone why so many they're
necessary the foundation racks up a body
count like it's going out of style and
it's your job to get that number as
close to zero as you can while not
getting yourself wiped off this rock my
name dr. Christopher is ardian MD yes I
know you've all got your MDS and
probably a few phd's you're all world
renowned surgeons and pathologists etc I
don't care and neither do your superiors
you're here to do a job and to be honest
it's gonna suck the good news the
forefront of medicine it's here right
here this is the place where you'll work
on super viruses strains of
Staphylococcus that would make your head
explode and viruses and bacteria which
had never heard before we work with
technologies and methods of treatment
that are deemed too dangerous and too
experimental
if you think you can't handle that I
suggest you leave now what hey what are
you doing sit back down
it was a joke this isn't voluntary
anyway what you'll see here is gonna
make or break you in some cases quite
literally now I know you're probably
wondering what I'm getting at but if I
told you in some cases you'd risk
exposure right there I've been working
here for less than five years and I've
seen pathologies that would make you
shudder to think of it happening to you
or even any other human being that being
said it's gonna be your job to log all
of what you see so that it doesn't
happen to your teams and your friends in
the containment division believe they'll
be your friends you'll certainly have to
patch him up enough yes doctor of course
you're expected to keep accurate records
you see this this is a standard case
file for a d-class that the research
staff we're exposing the one type of
virus you'll notice it's over 80 pages
long that's from one experiment we
perform hundreds in a given month it
should be noted that the paper copies
are only kept for experiments that are
deemed too vital to be left to
electronic storage so you write up this
extremely meticulous log and you might
be given a one-time mention about the
results and it is still format on the
database sucks but it's what happens
it's your job and you don't get to call
out
the d-class yeah you're gonna feel bad
for the d-class you really are they're
all terrible people but there's still
people you'll patch up spine snappings
and the lacerations of the throat you'll
remove rock candy for mucous membranes
and send them back to have it done to
them again this is horrifying yes
no it's your job now the foundation runs
on whether we like it to or not we are
the ones who keep it on its feet
not the researchers not even the
containment staff we'd without us
everything would pretty much go to hell
around here we have in containment right
now several viruses that if released
onto the world wouldn't be an epidemic
situation it would be a pandemic
guaranteed I'm sure some of the
pathologists here would be assigned to
the researching team and developing
countermeasures of course it goes
without saying that all these procedures
you learned back in med school about
cleanliness and disinfecting go double
while you're here well some of those
won't work either so you'll have to
follow the containment procedures for
the specific object you're working with
best case scenario for you will be
working in actual medical severe
lacerations or bullet wounds hopefully
it's only physical trauma god help you
if something infectious gets into your
lab some of you might even be assigned
to the site resident shifts and get it
easy keep in mind researchers aren't as
scrupulous about disinfecting after
experiments as we are you'd be amazed
what passes onto your microscope
maybe if you get a little less lucky
you'll deal with someone whose arm
spontaneously exploded then you'll have
to report what exactly the patient is
going through secondary symptoms etc if
you're assigned in a research capacity
rather than called in to treat the
injury your first job is to report
anything that's off or anomalous about
the trauma that's your job now the
patient comes second
you're kind of lucky you'll deal with
someone whose blood is boiling out of
his eyes as you speak to him these are
standard cases of no and SCPs these
aren't fabrications to scare you what if
you're not lucky you can become a
patient doctor something gets out gets
inside of you and we study you look let
me give you two major pieces of advice
one we're here to treat to heal and do
as we're told sometimes that might
involve breaking the Hippocratic oath
I'll sit down I know first you know
learn this however is the foundation if
anything gets out it's more than the
patient who will suffer
remember we're responsible for the lives
of countless thousands if one has to
suffer for it
they will besides if you don't do what
you're told you'll probably end up in
the front of an inquiry number two if a
patient is violent or carrying something
don't try to contain it yourself call a
containment team immediately don't risk
your own life we have precious few
doctors now and believe it or not
training a doctor takes more resources
than the foundation is generally willing
to expend without a damn good reason
for those of you who thought joining the
foundation turned you into dr. house or
James Bond think again you're here to do
a job keep that in mind at all times for
those of you who work outside of medical
assisting in the field keep your heads
down yeah you with the Bill Nighy bowtie
of course you'll be in danger have you
not been listening you could get shot at
exposed to a memetic hazard anything the
idea is to keep your head down follow
the instructions of the field agents and
try and come back in one piece yeah you
with the is that a top hat why in the
hell are you wearing a top hat never
mind never mind you're all dismissed try
not to get yourselves maimed on the
first week I don't want to see any of
you in the medical Bay okay
you